i think some of you are going to find
this pretty funny
uh one of the things that
by the way speaking of projection
one of the things the right criticizes
the left for
is this idea that anything goes
any opinion is valid and they call it a
form of post-modernism where everyone is
supposed to get an equal seat at the
table and we have to listen to all
opinions and value them and consider
them all equally now it's not true
it's not true
but as is often the case
it is they who are doing the very thing
which they accuse others of doing we
call this projection
charlie kirk a right-wing ideologue who
speaks
overwhelmingly to college-age people and
tries to convince them to become
right-wingers
he is now saying
inflation
may be caused by trans people by
transgender people
uh if i've ever seen an example of this
sort of
pseudo-post-modern
every opinion is valid
everything is connected sort of thing
it's this
take a listen to this uh this this is
this is beyond words
so one of the reasons why
we take such a strong stance and opinion
on the trans issue right is it's an
issue of reality
you do not get to determine your own
reality do not get to all of a sudden
say i'm rich or i'm poor no we actually
have to look at some evidence of whether
or not you're rich or poor now some of
those are relative terms rich according
to who which according to what i
understand that
but relatively tho some of the terms we
use short
tall you can't just make them up you say
oh wow that person is taller than that
person that person is faster than that
person fair and stronger than that
person so far so good and one of the
reasons why we've been so insistent
against this idea you can change your
gender
or change your sex or change both of
them
is that when you start to indulge
in the belief
that you could become whatever you want
and reality is subjective not objective
you're going to have ramifications that
nobody anticipated or intended okay so
there's a direct connection to
inflation
and the trans issue wow i say charlie
come on they couldn't be further apart
now they're exactly the same
they're the same in this aspect
when you believe that men can become
women
why wouldn't you also believe that you
could print wealth
oh man is it that's rich isn't it
isn't that there's about seven things
that have to be unpacked there if you
believe that someone can change their
gender why wouldn't you also believe
that money is wealth now there are very
simple laws of economics just like
there's laws of nature those laws of
physics laws of thermodynamics laws of
biology we must live we must live
according to those laws what's really
funny about this is so so so let me i'm
going to interpret what he's saying
he says
that
the ideology
that one can pick their gender
leads to inflation in so far as
saying you can pick your gender
is like saying you can print money
without causing inflation
neither is true
but that both are sort of magical
imaginary beliefs not based in reality
if you believe one you're likely to
believe the other if you believe anyone
can pick their gender you believe you
can just increase the money supply with
no effect and you're likely to do it the
people who believe you can pick your
gender
are more likely to believe you can
increase the money supply with no effect
and the problem with this is
it's so absurd that it's hard to even
discuss it on its merits but the the
general principle that applies here is
projection because i could turn this
around
this doesn't lead to productive
discussion is the point i'm trying to
make i could turn this around and go
listen charlie you know
the idea that you cut taxes for the rich
and it helps the economy
that just that's just imaginary that's
just as imaginary as anything else and
you can just link two things you can
just link any two things
if
vaccines
are related to trickle-down economics
david what what are you talking about
yeah i mean listen if the belief that
the vaccine doesn't work is just as
imaginary as the belief that cutting
taxes for the rich
is good for the economy
oh okay i've just linked them does this
actually substantively improve our
understanding of either of those issues
vaccination
or taxation no it doesn't and similarly
charlie kirk saying well the idea that
people can believe things that aren't
true can be used to link any two issues
it doesn't mean there's actually a
condition connection between trans
and inflation
what's the purpose of this though
the purpose is to start grouping
ideas they don't like together
even if they don't actually have any
business being grouped together with the
idea of convincing people by saying well
if you believe either of these things
you have to believe the other they must
both be wrong so i should reject both
both beliefs that's the idea it's to
weaponize the anti-trans people
when it comes to the economy under biden
or the other way around to weaponize the
economy under biden to convince people
that they shouldn't be for people being
able to live in the way that aligns with
the way that they feel so it's bogus it
doesn't lead to anything productive but
this is the ben shapiro type stuff that
you go to a college campus and people
hear and they go wow charlie's making a
lot of sense there it really makes a lot
of sense it's their version
of the anything goes post-modernism that
they say
exists exclusively on the left and
they're not going to stop because this
works he goes to college campuses and he
says this stuff and people just donate
they just give money they give money
money money it's extremely profitable
it's extremely effective and it's
extraordinarily depressing